this program is brought to you by Emory
University you said that I was your soul
mate I did you know that doesn't count
relationship thing I'm emotionally
unavailable yes I guess we should just
start so my daughter is just your slam
piece no no that's lame
blam away for this I could sing some
Third Eye Blind okay closing what's
striking about rhesus monkeys is that
it's not clear to us that the sexual
relations that occur within rhesus
monkeys are associated with any of the
kinds of emotions that we actually see
in humans so in one sense relevant to
the movie you might actually think that
the sexual relationship in rhesus
monkeys is like friends with benefits
there's not a long enduring sexual
relationship they don't even last from
year to year
they're very brief so what this means is
that the social environment can actually
have a big impact on whether or not sex
occurs the context determines very
strongly where we have sex and when we
have sex and the same is actually true
of rhesus monkeys that if they're in a
situation where there are negative
social cons consequences for engaging in
sex then it becomes very limited because
of the social structure in the social
context females essentially control what
goes on in a rhesus monkey group they
outnumber the male's they have tighter
social bonds female female bonds the end
result is that they control pretty much
everything including sex human culture
still is designed at best it's a parody
between males and females and I think
the sense is and sort of one of the
themes that's in this in this movie
friends-with-benefits is how difficult
it is once humans engage in sex to
disengage from the intimacy that the sex
produced and so I think rhesus monkeys
are perfectly capable of being friends
with benefits there are no long-term
consequences of it I think that in
humans it's a much more difficult
situation because sex changes everything
it's not simply just one other physical
event
it actually has emotional consequences I
think that a common theme between what
we know from rhesus monkeys and what we
know from humans is that sex actually is
not a behavior that can be taken lightly
even though rhesus monkeys don't form
sexual relationships even though they
may actually be promiscuous by human
standards in terms of their sexual
activity sex is actually still a very
difficult and challenging aspect of the
social life of rhesus monkeys it
threatens the social structure it
threatens mixing up the social structure
and so they've had to develop behavioral
ways of dealing with sex and I think the
same is true of humans the preceding
program is copyrighted by Emory
University